good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is scp-989 procedures
SCP 983 is completely safe so long as
technicians handling it do so on any
other day than their birthday should
scp-989 of their birth they should
immediately follow the sing-alongs
guidelines contained an emergency kit
one-three-five are located next to the
door to scp-989 stew meat sing-alongs
requirements their remains are to be
disposed of through standard methods in
the event the targeted individual meets
the sing-alongs requirements the
following pieces of data are to be
collected age color of candy collected
singing accuracy obtained by the best
judgment of those present and the number
of verses that passed before
acknowledgement bias EP 983
no candy obtained from a CP 983 is to be
consumed by any staff without senior
staff approved containment procedures in
place and written waivers filed and
stamped by the consumer this requirement
is waived in the case of Class D candy
testing description scp-989 its
manufacture at some point in the 1940s
by an unknown person or company the
monkey is dressed in the remains of what
used to be a popular vest designed for
circus Ringmaster's in the monkeys left
hand there is a lightly tarnished brass
bell in the right hand
the monkey holds a small brass striking
rod the monkey is capable of emitting
speech and sound
although examination of the object has
revealed no seams screw
or openings that would indicate a method
of this assembly
scp-989 stances and may be handled
without special precautions so long as
the handler is not experiencing the
24-hour period considered the
anniversary of his birth once scp-989
its bell and singing a simple song a
ring-a-ding-ding
it's your birthday this single verse
will be followed by the monkey striking
its bell producing a tone that varies in
pitch for a quite high to rather low
scp-989 a very excited and happy tone
scp-1981 severy three to four seconds
pausing only to ring its Bell until the
new owner has died or met the sing-along
requirements which as of yet are not
completely understood but are believed
to be based in timing the sing-along
properly with a CP 983 each verse sung
by scp-989 is estimated at one year by
singing along with scp-989 key which
once done successfully results in a
triumphant declaration of birthday from
a CP 983 at which time it will ring its
Bell once and produce a single gumdrop
style candy or the Bell the approach of
singing along with scp-1981 the color of
the candy and the side effects of its
consumption test groups instructed to
follow document 135 R to the letter have
verified that a perfect sing-along
results in the production of
crystal-clear candy with mildly
luminescent qualities a near-perfect
sing-along produces the same candy - the
luminescence both of these candy types
have been verified as restoring any age
lost by the consumer the
to scp-989 Essen candy may also grant
additional time and youth though as of
yet
this theory is unproven due to the low
production rate of this candy due to the
inconsistencies in attitude tone
behavior and approach when trying to
match scp-989 stances are black candies
allowed to be consumed although other
colors may be consumed pending prior
approval and containment arrangements
the initial activation of scp-989
controlled environment so a retelling is
the best record available of the
incident subsequent tests of interest in
more controlled environments have been
attached to this document as well as
candy effects for those experiments
scp-989
as CP 983 was purchased from a local
flea market intended as a gift for a
monkey admirer as a joke the seller of
the monkey warned the purchaser that it
was to be seen and never touched by
anyone on the day of their birth but was
unable to give exact reasons why stating
it was a warning passed to them that was
well observed and may have been gypsy
legend or some other book upon the
birthday of scp-989
the gift was unwrapped and the monkey
handled at which point it sprang into
song staff attending the birthday party
of their co-worker were amused as was
the recipient at first however witnesses
state the recipient became more and more
agitated the longer the monkey sang
after ten estimated verses the recipient
tried to find a way to turn the device
off to no avail attendees state that at
this time several persons noted streaks
of silver within the recipients hair
following an estimated eight to ten more
verses from SCP 983 the grey was quite
pronounced as were signs of wrinkling or
rests on the recipients face within five
more verses the recipient returned the
monkey to rest and complained of not
having the strength to deal with this
nonsense pleading for someone to turn it
off with scp-989 fully realized as a
potentially dangerous object there was
panic and sloth and the reactions of the
attending staff which led to scp-989
Leiby estimated at 30 or perhaps fifty
more verses before a containment crew
could arrive at the party locale by this
point the recipient had long since
expired due to aging leaving only a
skeletal frame remaining in his chair
with a skin clinging to it with
confusion on how to approach scp-1981
other minute before it ceased of its own
accord
at which point nothing remained of the
original recipient other than its purely
skeletal remains SCP 980 three's final
verse consisted of the single word
birthday which in announced joyously
before doing a single backflip and
ringing its bell once from the bell fell
a single candy resembling a gumdrop pure
black in color this candy was never
consumed and was described as being
moderately entrancing drawing a person's
gaze into it until an outside source
distracted them with a number of
individuals at the scene and the general
chaos involving the incident no single
person was able to become too focused on
the candy and it was safely contained
SCP 983 control and activation number 32
during test number 32 regarding a CP 983
one test subject volunteered for testing
as her birthday had approached and she
displayed qualities unique in comparison
to previous test subjects specifically
an exceptionally upbeat and excited
approach to her birthday is referred to
as the subject for the remainder of this
test without explanation as to what to
expect the subject was given scp-989
that this object sings and it would make
for a great birthday video if she were
to sing along with it the subject
displayed glee and acceptance of a CP
983 as a suitable gift when it was
unwrapped and required no guidance in
singing along with the object as it
began the subject went above and beyond
the singing requirements missing only
the first verse to get the words and
picking up immediately at the second
then continuing for a total of 45 verses
for a total of 46 completed during the
singing process the subject displayed
the expected aging process with each
verse that past but displayed no loss of
energy or enthusiasm in continuing the
songs till their end the subject
remained completely unaware of her
body's physical state throughout the
experiment upon completion of the final
verse scp-989 that finale as expected
with stating birthday loudly and
performing a single backflip followed by
a ringing of its bell the candy produced
from the Bell was recorded as being a
vibrant white color with vaguely
luminescent properties the subject noted
it was the most beautiful confectionery
that they had ever seen and observing
staff also noted admiration for the
gumdrop
in keeping with the control of the
experiment the subject was allowed to
consume the candy upon finishing the
candy and following a one-hour period of
monitoring there was no indication that
any side effect occurred from
consumption with the experiment about to
be declared finished the subject was
asked to leave and was excused from the
testing area at which point she exploded
with blinding light that damaged the
cameras monitoring the experiment and
left all attendees blind for five
minutes following the bursts assisting
personnel who rushed to the scene
described a faint lingering light that
remained for at least two minutes in the
place where the subject stood before
invaded out the subject has not been
located since this experiment and
unusually high electromagnetic activity
has been noted within the area that was
used for testing replacement of light
fixtures within this area has also risen
approximately 70 percent from the norm
throughout other areas of the facility
however no decrease in lighting has been
reported in any area affected by this
anomaly okay
apologies for my croaky sounding voice
today everyone I have a slight cold I
hope you forgive me now you probably
won't okay I'm gonna leave it there
today thank you all for listening if
indeed you still are and you are all
dismissed goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Pierce M Hamlin Muslim Mookie slump
God dr. day John Oh quarter
captain Gorge fluffy sky key mana moon a
my archive curator Nick tie verbal Kody
tench cheese whip I'm Depp's McGee thank
you all so much for your support I
really appreciate it if you would like a
special thank you at the end of each of
my videos on some other cool stuff as
well as at patreon.com forward slash the
vulcan thank you
you